I would like to make a statement to
update the house on the infected blood
inquiry uh the government welcomes the
publication of the infected blood
inquiry is second interim report I'd
like to thanks Brian langstaff and all
those who have contributed
the infected blood inquiry has done a
huge amount of work on an intensely
complex issue ensuring the victim's
voices are heard
I've been deeply moved by the
testimonies outlined in the latest
report
and the victim's bravery in coming
forward should not be overlooked
issuing of the second interim report
specifically on compensation was not
anticipated by the government until
we're informed by the inquiry in
February this year however we very much
appreciate and welcome sir Brian taking
this approach
the government is considering intensely
the recommendations outlined in this
report and work is underway at PACE
across all relevant departments to
respond fully
my right honorable friend the member for
maidenhead announced the infected blood
inquiry in 2017. to examine the
circumstances that led to individuals
being given contaminated blood and blood
products in the UK
the inquiry chaired by Sir Brian
langstaff commenced on the 2nd of July
2018. I'd like to reiterate our total
endorsement for my right honorable
friend's point that the contaminated
blood Scandal of the 70s and 80s should
simply never have happened
in tandem with the ongoing inquiry my
right honorable friend the member for
Portsmouth North as the then pay Master
General commissioner Robert Francis
Casey to produce a compensation at
framework study in anticipation of a
recommendation from the inquiry to set
up a compensation scheme
the findings of this study were
published in June 2022
shortly after this so Brian published
his first interim report of the affected
blood inquiry in July 2022 in his report
for Brian recommended that the
government make interim payments to
infected individuals and their bereaved
partners
the government accepted this
recommendation in full on the 17th of
August 2022 an interim compensation
payments of a hundred thousand pounds
have been paid to those infected
individuals and their bereaved Partners
registered with existing support schemes
as I said to the house in December we
have much to do and I wish to assure the
house that this is a priority for the
government and we will continue to
progress it those are my words in
December and I would like to assure the
house that this commitment absolutely
remains
so Brian's most recent report sets out
what the inquiry recommends as an
appropriate means of compensating both
those infected and affected and the
mechanism for delivering that
compensation
in doing so it sets out the complexity
of what is a multi-layered issue
the recommendations in his report
outline that those infected and affected
should be granted legal support and
infected and affected people and the
Estates of infected people should be
able to claim for categories of loss
against five Awards
injury impact award social impact award
autonomy award care award and financial
loss award
this is rather than claiming on
individual assessment of each
application
in addition those dissatisfied with
their compensation payments should have
redressed through an appeal to a
structure outside of the compensation
scheme
the report has also proposed mechanisms
so Brian thinks would ensure the
fairness of the compensation scheme he
is recommended that a scheme is
administered by an arm's length Body
chaired by a high court judge or
equivalent and advised by legal and
medical professionals as well as the
beneficiaries of the scheme
in addition to this so Brian has
proposed that the route through the
courts should still remain open to
beneficiarism
so Brian has agreed with much as a
Robert study though there are also
differences in approach
for example Sir Robert outlined in his
study that the scheme should be
delivered locally in each of the four
nations as this was the preference of
the victims
so Brian has recommended that the scheme
is delivered by a central body whilst
continuing the support provided by the
the existing infected blood support
schemes which should be continued and
guaranteed for life
by legislation or secure government
undertaking
there is also Divergence in the
consideration of scope of those eligible
for compensation payments including the
extension of payments to those with
hepatitis B and not providing payments
to the Estates of those affected
so Brian's interim report is detailed
and it's only right that the government
will need to consider the complexities
they set out thoroughly when preparing
our response
the house will recognize that health is
a devolved matter and I'll be discussing
the report with my colleagues in the
devolved Administrations
as I said at the start of my statement
the government welcomes the publication
of the infected blood inquiries second
interim report to assist its ongoing
work however we do not underestimate the
complexity of these recommendations
which do need careful consideration for
example so Brian recommends that an
arm's length body in which his Majesty's
government would have no ongoing role
Beyond providing taxpayer funds as
required by the body or anything like
this scale this would be in your
departure and does have implications for
accountability of government which will
need careful consideration alongside how
its financial implications will be
managed
I would however like to reassure the
house but while the government is
progressing work to ensure that we are
in the best possible position to respond
fully at the end of the inquiry every
recommendation by Sir Brian including in
relation to timing and a further interim
payment is receiving intense Focus
my colleagues in the department for
Health and Social care are aware of the
issues that Brian has raised in relation
to psychological support
under the current psychological support
scheme for England there is provision
for a grant of up to 900 pounds a year
for established beneficiarism family
members for counseling and talking
therapy the department for Health and
Social care is undertaking research to
look at the psychological support needs
that so the decisions on commissioning
of the spokes service are based on
robust evidence and meet the requirement
in closing I would like to referee the
need for Pace people die
every week as a result of the impact of
the Scandal
this government wants to deliver
resolution and we are working at PACE
across all relevant departments to
consider the recommendations as outlined
in this latest report and to ensure we
are best replaced to respond to the
inquiries final report I commend this
statement to the house
Shadow Minister Fleur Anderson
thank you Deputy speaker and I thank the
payment general for providing an
advanced copy of his statement I'd like
to begin by paying tribute to the brave
victims and their families who whilst
working through their own personal ill
health grief and Trauma have campaigned
tirelessly for justice without their
strength we would not have reached this
stage and of course to my right
honorable friend the member for Kingston
upon Hull North who's been a stalwart of
the success of this campaign so far the
continued work of the infected blood
inquiry is crucial to ensuring that
victims voices are heard I had the
privilege of meeting with victims of
this Scandal last month and their
stories will stay with me forever no one
should have to experience the pain and
anguish they have faced and are still
facing Justice delayed continuing to be
delayed is Justice denied
while we await the conclusion of the
report and inquiry those who were given
contaminated blood products are dying at
a rate of one every four days
families have suffered Decades of health
issues Financial loss and stigma
victims those affected and infected will
have watched The Minister's statement
today with heavy hearts and
disappointment and some degree of anger
there seems to be no commitment from the
minister to respond to the second report
until the final report is published in
the autumn
the interim report was published so that
the government doesn't have to wait and
to take action until the final report
whilst we all understand the
complexities of this Scandal I hope the
minister can see that many individuals
directly affected still feel angry and
unrecognized today's statement does not
provide any certainty for the families
or children of victims so Madam Deputy
speaker I have five questions for the
minister to finish with first does he
agree with sir Brian's statement in the
interim report that time without redress
is harmful no time must be wasted in
delivering that redress and can he
confirm that the intense Focus that he's
talked about being done now to achieve
is to achieve the recommendation in the
report that the scheme is set up now and
should begin work this year second how
can he provide more reassurance to
family members of victims including
parents who lost children and children
orphaned when their parents died
third the paymaster general talked about
work underway if the government plans to
accept these interim findings officials
must start now verifying registering
directly affected people and their
families urgently to understand the size
of the group and to speed up the
payments can he confirm whether this is
already taking place fourth will he
commit to more regular updates on the
progress and direction of travel on this
issue ahead of the inquiry's final
report later this year we shouldn't have
to keep squeezing this information out
of the government because it compounds
the pain of the victims
and finally will he agree to meet with
me and my right and old friend the
shadow Chancellor of the Dutch of
Lancaster so that we can work together
to deliver the Justice the victims to
serve
minister
thank you madam Deputy speaker
um and I'm very unloaded for her uh her
remarks she was right paid tribute to
many MPS in this house uh including
young writable lady and my normal friend
who have really campaigned tardisi on
this over a long period of time I'm
grateful for the work of the appg and
I'd also actually mention some of the
members of the media who've actually
been absolutely the Forefront of pushing
this for a long period of time but above
all
The Honorable lady is right to refer to
the victims and I know I'm very
conscious of the fact that there will be
tens of thousands of people watching
this statement today who are desperate
to see a resolution of this every time
there is another iteration every time
there is a cause for me to be in this
place it is a source of anxiety and of
concern and of worry and of I'm afraid
I'm I'm sure disappointment uh every
time there is another statement and we
don't have the final uh resolution
what I would say is we've traveled a
long way so it was six years ago this
was announced it was five years ago that
sir Brian started work uh I'm very very
grateful to Sir Brian for producing this
interim report it has a lot of it is
very similar to Sir Robert Francis
report that there are differences we do
need to do the work so on the points
that the uh The Honorable lady raises
um
there is a we've been
focused on ensuring that at the
conclusion of some Brian's inquiry we're
able to come forward in the very best
place the best place possible to do it
that is not preclude doing something
earlier if we are able and have the
means uh to do it uh registration is not
as yet taken place but I'm absolutely uh
mindful of the fact that whereas for the
previous interim uh payment there was a
defined set of people and bereaved
Partners were that recommendation to be
taken forward that requires registration
and that inevitably takes time as we are
all aware I absolutely
will continue to although uh honorable
members right honorable members will be
aware uh that this is no more than an
update statement I was Keen to come to
this house to hear the views of
honorable members that I commit to do so
again as appropriate as we continue
through uh this process and work will
continue and of course it would be a
pleasure to meet The Honorable lady in
the shadow transfer of the duchy if
they'd like to meet uh to discuss this
uh chair of the health select committee
Steve Bryan thank you very much uh in
his second interim reports sir Brian
langstaff makes it clear that the
government has everything it needs to
implement the conversation framework now
and to repeat the shadow ministers quote
that she's pulled out from the report
very pertinent time without redress is
harmful I would suggest that is rather
underplaying it time without address
people are passing away currently Madame
Deputy speaker these infected blood
support schemes make regular ex-glacier
payments to those who are infected and
bereaved Partners will the government
make this provision statutory
Minister
um I thank my honorable friend for the
question and I look I don't dispute for
a second uh the comments that have been
of Sir Brian that has been referred to
by The Honorable friend and The
Honorable lady uh that time without
address is harmful
we want to see progress on this which is
why we are working at PACE to deliver it
the sublime makes a specific
recommendation that the ongoing
expression payments should be put on a
factory basis or receive a similarly
strong government uh uh commitment I I'm
not in a position to responding to
recommendations today it's been eight
working days since the report landed but
all of these all of these
recommendations will be taken very
seriously
SNP spokesperson Martin day thank you
madam Deputy speaker may I put on the
record my gratitude for advanced site of
the statement today and also for the
work of the infected blood inquiry I
suspect there will be a considerable
amount of consensus in the house on this
issue I have over the years been
appalled at this personal Testament I've
heard from my constituents that 40 Years
of struggle and the realization that
this Scandal could have affected any one
of us it is a tragedy which simply
should never have happened and it has
been made Washed by Decades of delay
first in preventing further use of
contaminated Factor products and
identifying victims and then in
delivering compensation and as we know
the infected blood Scandal took place
before Devolution or health care in
Scotland was the responsibility of the
UK government and the financial powers
to deliver compensation still live with
Westminster it is entirely appropriate
to therefore have a scheme delivered by
a central body as recommended by the
inquiry over the years there have simply
been too many delays and denials
impacting victims and their families as
the brain life staff he's absolutely
spot on when he says in the interim
report and we've heard this a couple of
times already today but I make no
apology for repeating it time without
redress is harmful no time must be
wasted in delivering that address it is
therefore imperative that the
recommendations to widen the interim
compensation payments are carried out
and this should be done before the final
compensation scheme is set up so will
the UK government accept the
recommendation of the inquiry that the
interim compensation payments be widened
and delivered without delay and finally
a queen will the compensation systems
independent chair be appointed can we
have a detailed time scale for this
minister
I Thank The Honorable for his comments
and can I also thank him particularly
for him welcoming uh the concept of a
central body that was an area of
um uh of not dispute but there was a
slightly different uh emphasis placed
between sir Robert's report and to
Brian's report as whether it should be
delivered uh locally through each of the
four schemes or uh through a UK scheme
the the 100 was absolutely right this
happened in the 70s and 80s long before
uh the evolution and there's a clear
recommendation from Sir Brian which I'm
glad to hear that the honorable
gentleman uh endorses
um there is a he raises two points about
the interim compensation payment being
widened and uh there being no delay in
its implementation and also regarding
the appointments of uh individuals this
all depends on the government's response
to each of those recommendations the
only gentleman will accept that there
are a number of things that could be
done though to speed up the process uh
it takes if we were to go down the route
if we were to agree with Ryan's
recommendation to have an ALB the raw
mechanisms whereby individual could be
appointed on a interim basis prior to
the ALB being formally constituted and
all of this is in the mix as we work
through our response to his report
that father of the house speaker
the main views from the old party group
will come from the Revel uh lady
can I say to the minister we recognize
there's going to be a great deal of work
that needs to go into this
as a minimum
can I put to him did you come back to
the house
for the summer break to say how far the
government has got in considering
recommendations and which ones they're
going to accept
can I ask him if you'll set up a
register to those who think they will
have claims to make can both put their
names forward and Beyond able to receive
updates from government directly rather
than just from the mainstream media
and can I say to him that
the voices of formal sexual safe for
health that the totality has been a
failure by the British State and that
the pain and suffering has gone on far
too long a words endorsed right across
the house and by the country as a whole
and that we want the action that sabran
langstaff has asked for which is the
scheme should be set up this year
minister
I thank my radical friend uh and I thank
him for recognizing there is a great
deal of work to be done which there is
um I've already referred to the to the
to the register Point
um were we to adopt the uh
recommendation which is a very clear
recommendation from Brian about an
interim payment uh which goes more why
didn't the last scheme that does require
a registration scheme and I appreciate
that that would take time itself so that
needs to be established at a very early
stage if that recommendation is accepted
I will come back and update the house I
will do so as is appropriate
um I hope that would certainly involve
before the summer uh break
and can I thank the minister for making
the statement today
but really
after thousands have died Decades of
campaigning a five-year public inquiry
with over 500 people dying during that
five-year period a review of
compensation Frameworks by Sir Robert
Francis delivered to the government last
February a first interim report from Sir
Brian landstaff and now a second interim
report from Sir Brian landstaff setting
out the clear case for compensation
enough is enough yeah
so Brian Langster is very clear in his
report he says the scheme need not await
the final report to Begin work it will
clearly take political will to act
quickly but the circumstances here
warrant it so can the minister explain
to me and the thousands of people will
be watching this statement this
afternoon what exactly is the problem
why isn't the political will from this
government to deliver Justice to this
group of people
Minister I I found that right on the
lady she has been a constant and
Incredibly effective Champion
for those affected and infected uh I'm
it is it was about time but it was this
government that did Institute this
inquiry we've made a huge amount of
progress in having an inquiry in having
a very clear recommendations on
compensation coming from uh sir Brian
um we want to act at PACE and we want to
act swiftly but it's also vital this is
done properly so there is a huge amount
of work the uh nature of the report the
recommendations that Brian makes they
are unprecedented for an unprecedented
circumstance but that does require
detail work and detailed analysis we
will bring forward our response as soon
as we can I say we are focused on the
inquiries conclusion that doesn't
preclude coming forward before that if
we are able to do so and if we decide
that that is the right course of action
Matt Hancock thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker can I add my voice to
those thankings to Brian langstaff and
the whole team for the work that they've
done we all recognize the complexities
of delivering a scheme that's effective
and I'm grateful to the minister for
repeatedly coming to this house and
committing to come to the house again
but will he repeat from the dispatch box
the moral case for compensation which
effectively has bound the government to
act and to follow the recommendations
for compensation whilst of course it
takes time to put that into practice
what it is vital I think for people to
hear today is that in principle the
government is going to make this happen
because for many years that commitment
was not there and it needs to be
repeated now
minister
um
am I right on my friend speaks with a
great day of knowledge on this um on
this subject and I
I'm very grateful I repeat this as did
he I'm very grateful to Brian for
producing a comprehensive and thorough
uh appraisal of what the compensation
scheme should look like we need to go
through that in detail as I read on my
phone would accept it needs to be
effective it needs to work but I'm
pleased that he's given me the
opportunity to reiterate what I said
last uh December in this place uh that
we've fully accept there is a moral case
for compensation in this circumstance
absolutely
Dr Philippa Whitford thank you very much
Madam Deputy speaker as I've said in the
debate in 2017 I remember as a young
surgeon with this Scandal began to break
in the early 80s 40 years ago my entire
medical career has passed while people
have been fighting for justice and
recognition and dragging that out has
added financial hardship to the
suffering that people were already going
through so as The Honorable lady from
Whole North I think said
enough is enough so the minister has
talked about how long things will take
and we recognize that but when will they
start when will registration of bereaved
parents and children start when will the
framework actually start so that people
can expect as a Brian Lang staff called
for that they would see action this year
not waiting
Minister The Honorable lady is very
clear as is Brian in his report so
there's no dispute as to what Sabrine is
um uh recommending I I can't give that
commitment now there are process across
government as the young lady will
understand
um we are working at PACE we are going
through uh the the report in great
detail as I say it's it's been a short
period of time since that report uh
landed uh with us uh and on all of us
and it is detailed it is comprehensive
and it does need work but we will be
coming back to the honorable lady into
this house
to Mike Penning Adam Deputy speaker
Madam new speaker mode the first Shadow
portfolio I had in 2006 was the shadow
Health minister with this portfolio so I
met many of the victims straight away
that I've been crying out from the 80s
is when this started but actually we
didn't really know until into the 90s
what was creating it and I'm no expert
on this but that's the sort of thing
that was coming forward so I'm very
proud that this government has done
something
though I promise as the minister what we
would do to those victims but it's been
taken too long
if there is a moral position for this
the victims out there are still
suffering their loved ones are suffering
if they've lost their loved one and it's
not just Financial it's actually broken
people's hearts and Minds as well
but their skepticism on this I think
might be also fueled by the fact that
the government initiated an inquiry by
baroness cumberlich
into the primordos debacle and disaster
and the government ignored that
literally ignored their own inquiry so
can the minister understand the concerns
of victims and other members of this
house
they are a little bit skeptical about
delay delay delay
um
my rightful friend is is uh he's
absolutely right this has been a long
long term uh Scandal when it started in
the 70s and 80s it has been many many
years to get to this stage but the stage
we've now got to is a high court judge a
very distinguished high court judge has
spent five years working through the the
circumstances he is an advanced stage
with his inquiry and he has produced a
thorough report on compensation
um as I've said to this house and I will
say it again the moral case for
compensation is fully accepted by the
government we do need to go through this
and work through exactly what the
implications are which are multiple and
this is as I said before there's an
unprecedented circumstance which
requires unprecedented uh means of
redress and that is what's reflected in
the uh in the report but it does require
work to go through it
live effort
we've had the report set out by Sir
Brian Lang staff that says how the
compensation should be delivered the
framework for delivering it the minister
has said that the government is
considering this recent report at PACE
and he has also said that he wants to
come back and update the house so if
we're moving at PACE and we have all the
detail in place that we need when is he
going to come back to the house
minister
um I will
it'll be a great pleasure to return to
the house with more substance when I can
I thought it's important even though we
have only received the uh this
comprehensive report eight working days
ago to give members of this house an
opportunity to share their views on that
interim report at the earliest possible
opportunity but the entrepreneur will
realize that it does require work to
come back uh substantively to say which
recommendations uh are being accepted
and how we would be uh progressing it
uh James Morris Deputy speaker can I
welcome The Minister's statement but
would you agree with me that
notwithstanding the complexity that he
outlined in relation to the compensation
scheme that two things should happen one
is that the government should move
urgently to the design of the
compensation scheme and secondly in in
the design of the compensation scheme
um there should be engagement with
victims or the groups representing those
victims to make sure that there is
alignment between the compensation
scheme and the expectation of victims
moving forward
Minister I look I totally understand uh
where my honorable friend is coming from
uh the it is critical that we produce uh
that answers provided to in response to
this uh uh report are ones that have the
uh that are readily understood and have
the buy-in of all those who've suffered
so grievously as a result of these uh
scandals I'm very keen to engage with
the victims I would also say uh that uh
sir Brian I think has been uh doing a a
an exceptional job in ensuring that he
fully understands and speaks and takes
on board the comments made uh by the
victims and engages with them it is I
think impossible for any of us who have
not suffered from this ourselves
personally to understand fully the
anguish that those victims have been put
through I think so Brian has done his
utmost to reflect that in the report
that is produced
and yes I'd also like to thank the
minister for coming here today and pay
tribute to Brian and the work that he
has done
not long after I was first elected in
2017 I received a letter from a
constituent whose family had suffered as
a result of the infected blood Scandal
and what they had been through was
heartbreaking
and although progress has been made and
we have the incident report we are now
six years further on
and they are no further on in receiving
compensation so as others have said
today can we please get on with it and
ensure that these families suffering is
put to an end
Minister
um look I I totally understand where the
honorable lady is coming from uh that we
all have constituents who are in that
situation there are tens of thousands of
people who are affected across the whole
of the UK we want to do so at PACE we
also want to do so the scheme that is
that any scheme adopt must be effective
and must work and must be appropriate so
there is work on going we will get there
and report back to the house our
response to those recommendations that
Sabrina's make at Mark Pritchard Madam
speaker can I welcome Minister's intense
focus on this but can I join members
from across is not on a personal basis
because I think the minister is one of
the best in the government but on behalf
of my constituents that this has taken a
long time and of course it has to be
thorough and I'd like to put on record
my thanks to Sir Brian and and Sir
Robert but can the minister assure the
house that their difference of opinion
about how the conversation May or not be
delivered whether nationally or through
the devolve administrations will not
cause further delay that posts the final
report being published there won't then
be a further consultation on whether
it's devolved or national and in
particular on children affected uh
who've lost loved ones and parents
whether there could be interim payments
more quickly because then some of them
are really suffering financially let
alone the loss of their parents and on
the five categories he mentions social
impact clearly the loss of a parent is
the biggest social impact of all
um traditional my honorable friend uh
when I referred in my statement to areas
where there were different nuances
different views presented by Robert and
Brian I I don't want that to be over
overstated and I wouldn't have wished to
have done so
um so Brian had the benefit of Robert's
report I think I think he would say that
he found it extremely useful that that
study was undertaken so he was able to
uh consider uh sir Robert's report for
coming up with his own recommendations
uh but we must not allow any difference
between the two which is mainly of
nuance to get in the way of uh our
proper and full consideration of Sir
Brian's uh report uh the uh The
Honorable judgment also refers as of
other uh honorable members to uh interim
payments all I can say is that there is
a very clear recommendation from uh sir
Brian uh we are working through all of
this and we will be returning to the
house in in due course having had an
opportunity to review fully of those
recommendations
Papa Keely
thank you madam Deputy speaker Michael
treatment the family did not feel they
could grieve openly because of the
stigma around HIV and AIDS at the time
of his death
Michael search once told me that
although a compensation payment would
not bring back their father it would
finally give the family A sense of
closure
does the minister accept the symbolic
importance of compensation payments and
will the government now commit to
including children who have lost a
parent in the scope of the compensation
scheme as recommended by sobriety
Minister uh I I think the one of the
very very worst aspects of many Dreadful
aspects of this Scandal is the stigma to
which The Honorable lady uh refers to go
as a child through the circumstances of
being extremely illness for your parents
to then have be worried about the stigma
and moving house or moving school or
moving work it is it is deeply for those
of the shock of reading it now
um and in many cases we're 20 30 40
years on from the circumstances it it is
it is an absolute uh it actually hell
these people went through with the
stigma laid on top of dreadful um
circumstances and I'm grateful to The
Honorable lady for reminding us of that
I'm afraid I'm not in a position though
to uh make piecemeal uh comments
regarding the recommendation that Brian
has made I think it is as I've said
before it's vital that he produced this
report it's a very comprehensive report
and we do need to go through it
thoroughly and then produce a a response
in due course we've had a chance to do
so Kevin Foster thank you madam Deputy
speaker you know the length of this
Scandal because some can be summed up
with the fact that my predecessor spent
18 years pursuing certain cases and I've
spent the last eight years pursuing the
same cases to try and bring them to
resolution now the minister rightly says
there's work to be done following these
recommendations but what time scales has
he set for that work to be done to in
terms of them being able to prepare a
response and also what work has been
done in preparation for potential
recruitment of people to actually deal
with medicines by the structure proposed
can never experience with another
complex compensation scheme stretching
over decades that is far easier said
than done yeah
my model friend raises good points uh
there is a work was undertaken prior to
the uh release of the second interim
report uh based on Sir Robert's original
study which helps us considerably uh we
will we're now working at PACE to go
through uh the uh changes but also going
through what the government starts will
be overall but we are working at PACE I
want to set a timeline to it but we are
um on recruitment uh modern firm race is
a good point that if a ALB route is the
way forward uh there's no time needs to
be lost in uh finding a route for good
people who've got expertise to be
brought into the process prior to the uh
formal establishment of an ALB if that's
the roof again
200. with Madam Deputy speaker of the
gut-wrenching truth of the matter is
that people are decaying and dying while
his government Dithers and delays the
people who are concerned in this will
have heard no nothing new today from the
minister so can he for their benefit so
they know he's fighting for them confirm
that he believes the recommendations to
widen the scope of the payment should be
agreed and will he fight for those
compensation payments that we made this
year to the people affected
minister
um what I would say to 100 is that the
it would be wrong to characterize the
circumstance today as the being one of
no progress the fact that sir Brian
langstaff has producers report is a huge
step forward as I say it is fantastic
that he has come forward with the second
interval report specifically on
compensation
um
I already accepted on behalf of the
government I speak on behalf of the
government on behalf of the government I
accepted the moral case of compensation
uh back in December we now need to go
through uh what Brian has written which
has been the culmination of many years
work and then take decisions on that and
then come back to the house
thank you madam Deputy speaker and I
welcome the government's clear
determination as shown by the minister
today to move faster towards a just
resolution to this sad and terrible
Scandal as an MP representing a
Huntington family devastated by this
affair who were long concerned at the
inability to engage with ministers will
my right honorable friend now confirm
that ongoing engagement with victims
families will take place with proper
understanding for their tragic flight
minister
um thank you uh speaker and I'm
confirmed my rottenham friend yes if
there's I I previously met I think most
of us in our constituency capacities
have been aware of the victims of this
Dreadful Scandal uh through the right
honorable lady in the appg I had the
privilege of meeting representatives of
those infected and affected and I'm more
than willing to do so again as we
continue to progress our work on this
you're correct thus tens of thousands of
people fixed to the televisions that
they're expecting a resolution to this
inquiry
that disappoint I'll tell you why
they're disappointed Minister because I
haven't got time on the side
there's hundreds have already died and
there's more dying on a week by week
basis but haven't got time on the side
so we need to ensure that the government
respond fully to this report we need to
ensure that the government set out a
clear timetable on actions for this
report remember there's people dying as
a government or dead ring in delaying
Minister the uh The Honorable gentleman
is absolutely right alas that the
victims of this continue to die and
Ashley so Brian makes a comment in his
second interim report that uh we don't
necessarily know the full scale of the
medical impact of what went on uh in the
70s and 80s and conditions are in some
cases uh worsening so the the point is
absolutely uh well made uh the only
gentleman says we must respond fully uh
we must and we will and we will do so
when we have done uh the work that is
required Damian Moore thank you madam
Deputy speaker and I welcome on behalf
of my constituents affected by this the
sensitivity in which the government has
been dealing with however uh the lack of
urgency is undermining that Goodwill on
behalf of victims and their families and
it's letting victims and their families
down every single day how long is it
going to be between accepting one of
these points and implementing them would
it not just be easy to implement them
now and I think speaking and listening
to members and the way they've spoken
today the best thing to do would be to
implement them and work on getting these
support to families as soon as possible
minister
um I I the the uh there is urgency I can
assure him in terms of our response as
it was eight working days ago that the
report was uh produced we are working at
peace to go through it we will continue
uh to do so we need to determine our
view on all of those recommendations
um but that does not necessarily
preclude us taking individual steps
between now and the conclusion of the uh
inquiry and we will continue to work
Jessica Morden thanks for
thanks
please don't delay this any longer I
know the minister will say it's
complicated he said that of the last
statement but the government's known
about this for a long long time and
should have been preparing and bereave
family like Louis families like the
Smiths in my constituents use case I've
been waiting for 18 years now need
interim payments now does the minister
really get that those who have waited
years for justice and from a redress
just can't afford to wait any longer
yeah
I'm I'm
familiar with the conceptions the case
of the honorable lady she's raised it
many many times and I'm familiar with
the uh with the sad story which is uh
one of so many around this house I I
cannot add what I've heard earlier I
recognize the strength of feeling in
this house uh and in the infected and
affected uh communities we absolutely do
and I'm grateful that we have Mr Brian's
report
um a a really thorough analysis for us
to work through
Chris Stevens thank you Deputy speaker
does the minister accept that the
uncertainty of when the government will
fully respond to their support risks
damaging people's mental health uh I'm
thinking of a number of constituents
who've contacted me that there's a real
impact of mental health and so can we
can he say an actual timetable or does
he have a timetable on his head uh for
action and does he also accept the
principle of making interim payments to
breed parents and children many of whom
give up the working careers many of whom
did not reach their educational and
academic potential because of the years
they were caring for their loved ones
minister
um on the on the on the timetable Madam
Deputy speaker
we are determined to be in the best
possible place to respond to the uh
inquiry when it concludes because I've
said to other uh honorable members that
doesn't preclude us doing other uh steps
earlier uh if that is what we determined
to do as a government we are working a
pace to go through all of the
implications of the report on the second
point that Beyond gentleman raises I I
can't uh go through individual
recommendations at this stage he'll
appreciate why but I do recognize the
extremely strong case uh that uh Brian
has made uh for a number of those who
have been affected including carers
who've given up a great deal to support
others
thank you
thank you Michael
Stitch contractor
in the 1980s her daughter wrote to me
last year and I quote she said I'm
furious that you have grudgingly decided
to pay interim compensation after she
finally could fight no longer seven
weeks after she died in the meantime I'm
left with grief and nothing else to show
for all the misery in addition to all
the horrors that Michael's dituent and
her mother went through the daughter is
also not eligible for compensation as
she's not a partner of the bereaved
could I ask the minister does he think
this is fair
okay
minister
look I'm very sorry to hear about the um
the the loss of the The Honorable ladies
uh constituent it is it was a
significant step forward and a positive
step forward that the government uh
accepted in full surprise recommendation
about those infected and bereaved
partners and brought forward the 100 000
pounds of uh compensation that was paid
last October it's tragic that for the
reason stated earlier in relation to the
the scale of loss ongoing uh from uh
from this Scandal that the will have
been individuals who missed out on those
compensation uh because they uh because
of that that even between the
announcement and and the payment of the
compensation uh which is uh and I really
feel for the family of uh of the
honorable leaders constituent
um the unrelated specifically referred
uh to uh payments to to beyond the
interim payments were made last year uh
so Brian has made a very specific
recommendation on that we're not
responding to it uh today but if there's
one many recommendations that we're
working through Alison Taylor's thank
you madam Deputy speaker my
constituent's father died in England in
the late 1970s and she tells me that she
has his only surviving next of Ken so
can the minister confirm where my
constituent and many others like her
will obtain the compensation that they
are clearly due and what proof will be
required to access it given the
notorious related Scandal around medical
records because people in these
circumstances don't need more barriers
they need compensation after all they've
suffered here minister
the I don't believe it and she raises an
extremely good point in terms of the
evidence to be produced to access any
future compensation uh scheme it was a
minor point of difference between the
two reports for Mr Robert and uh uh sir
Brian in terms of the evidential uh test
but everyone is very aware uh that given
the history of Records not being
available and the length of time that
has been passed a uh well so Brian has
been very clear that a um an appropriate
approach must be taken to a compensation
scheme if it's established along those
lines to ensure that it doesn't preclude
people who have got no means of
um of of showing their ability to access
the scheme because in fact has
completely beyond their control
Holly Lynch thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker it's a point that's been
made by so many colleagues in the
chamber already but children of those
lost as a consequence of the Scandal
feel particularly unseen and unheard by
the progress It's been made so far so
can the minister assure them that there
will be a focus for this government when
recognizing not only their loss but also
in delivering compensation payments
through the scheme to them as a priority
Yes Minister
as I said before children particularly
hiring aspect of this uh so Brian has
made very specific recommendations we're
not responding to those today but we are
working through them we will continue to
do so I can assure them
Patrick Grady Deputy speaker I express
sympathy and solidarity of my
constitutes have been affected as well
does the minister accept as I think the
questions are demonstrating that the
longer it takes to implement the more
complicated it's going to become and not
least because of the question of Estates
and surviving relatives becomes
increasingly into play so does the
government recognize the need to confirm
the individuals that are due
compensation and then pay them as
quickly as possible
can you stop
a vulnerable gentleman president that is
exactly the process that we're going
through it's working through uh sir
Brian's report where you make specific
recommendations including uh the
eligibility of the states who recommends
that the estate so for those infected
should be included with any scheme these
are all uh he's not wrong in saying that
these are all complicated risks becoming
more complicated and we want to make
certain that we make progress and come
to a resolution
um and our consideration of that report
Catherine West
Deputy speaker when I entered this house
my young constituent was in the nursery
and we all hoped that this would be
resolved quickly she then graduated to
primary school and now she's about to go
into Secondary School the loss of her
father was absolutely devastating to
this terrible infected blood scandal
two questions one is will she receive
compensation because there seems to be a
question about whether children will get
compensation and secondly the
psychological research is only being
done now to look at the support needs
how can it be that after this many years
that the research is only beginning now
to look on Commercial commissioning a
bespoke service and really apologize for
that specific delay
minister
I I can't confirm
um the the details of what would be
within a compensation scheme that brings
comes forward uh simply because that is
the work we are undertaking now I
recognize the urgency represented by The
Honorable lady in terms of the
psychological needs there are uh
different uh progress has been made
around the United Kingdom there are
schemes established in in Scotland and
Wales and Northern Ireland uh there is
900 pounds available every year uh in in
uh in England
um but there is being work undertaken
now to ensure that there is that a
tailored scheme
um would be absolutely appropriate and
that is ongoing
um and we expect to hear uh over the
next few months as to what the answer
will be on the psychological scheme
that's something which has been
conducted by my uh ministerial
colleagues in the Department of Health
Nevada
because I am afraid that it's simply not
good enough it is like Groundhog Day for
our constituents who've been impacted by
the contaminated blood Scandal and it's
not good enough to come to the dispatch
box when there's been so much time and
so many reports with so little to say to
our constituents constituents like mine
Vita Gaskin and Linda Cannon Linda
emailed me last night to say the
consequences for me have been
devastating my life has been ruined
beyond belief I lost my husband 37 of 37
years under horrendous circumstances
which were hard to Bear decades have
gone by Madame Deputy speaker and
nothing has been done we welcome the
reports of course we welcome the reports
but the minister must not use those to
hide behind and kick the can down the
road for those victims there's clearly
cross-party support for taking those
internal measures so why doesn't he get
on and do it
Minister
um The Honorable lady is absolutely
right this has been going on for decades
that was why it was vital that the
inquiry was set up as it was uh in 2017
by Mario from the friendly member for
maidenhead uh this is a significant
moment in the course of that inquiry uh
the production of an interim report
specifically dealing with compensation
was delivered eight working days ago
it's extraordinarily important that
that's been made it is a thorough report
we need to go through it so I I I I
recognize the uh determination from all
sides of this house uh to see this to uh
resolution I recognize the frustration
of The Honorable lady and she's
reflecting the frustration of her
constituents and many others I know but
it was only during the Easter assess
this report was established we need to
work through it and we need to come back
to this house when we've done that work
Charlotte Nichols thank you madam Deputy
speaker today's statement is
a light on substance or
and there is no reason
begin verifying and registering those
affected in preparation for the
publication of the final report for the
Swift Delivery of compensation The
Minister's own statement reiterates the
need for pace and yet there's no
commitment to even beginning this or a
vague timeline when this might be begun
at a time when victims are dying every
week and we're in a sustained cost of
living crisis
Justice delayed is Justice denied why is
the government causing further
unnecessary delays with their inaction
have the victims and their families not
already suffered more than enough
minister
the I look I I recognize the
determination of The Honorable lady
um it is fair to say that in terms of
registering those who may be eligible
for a future compensation scheme those
register would have varied between the
Sir Robert uh Francis study and the
report produced by uh sir Brian
langstaff so we do need to do the work
we do need to ensure that we have
absolute Clarity on which way which
approach we're taking and that that is
announced and there is Clarity for uh
for the victims but I actually couldn't
I I there will be no unnecessary delays
as The Honorable lady uh puts it there
is however a need and a necessity to do
the work to make certain that we have an
effective and proper and appropriate
response to what is a very thorough
report
Jamie Stone
thank you very much Mr Speaker
um I have a constituent called Brian
Ross and I have his permission to use
his name here
uh his family had been known to my
family for Generations he received
contaminated blood of the 1980s and like
so many others has left susceptible to
cancer and I sat down with him and I've
talked to him about the stress the fear
the really black fear that surrounds him
and his family
um
for Brian Ross is sick can I ask the
minister to make sure that nothing
impedes some scheme for him we don't
know how long he's got and in working
with the victims their legal
representatives and indeed he mentioned
the minister mentioned the devolved
institutions let's make sure that
nothing is a glitch in all this and
please do this for brown Ross's sake
uh The Honorable open speaks from uh
from the heart and I totally recognize
uh the issues that he raises on behalf
of his constituent Mr Ross I can only
reiterate that we've come a long way on
the subject 2017 this is established we
now have a thorough report uh
specifically on compensation that is a
major step forward from where we were at
any stage prior uh to eight days ago and
we will do all the work and ensure that
we come back with a proper and full and
appropriate response with Cadbury thank
you madam Deputy speaker my constituent
son uh received infected blood in the
80s and the trauma and cost on that
family is incalculable as described by
many other constitu MPS here today time
is not on the side of many of these
families
I'm going to ask the paymaster general a
specific question because he seems to
avoid giving any specific facts of
what's going to happen now
is it not unreasonable to have a
compensation scheme up and running by
the end of this year
minister
um that is what Brian recommends
so Brian believes that it is possible to
achieve that we need to work through and
produce our response to zebran I'm not
in a position to confirm timings as yet
all of what our response will be but the
honorable Aid is absolutely right in
saying that Ryan langstaff recommends uh
that we should be in a position to go
the scheme in place by the end of the
year we need to do the work we need to
be able to come back to this house
Stuart C McDonald thank you madam
speaker first of all argue in favor of
the importance of the independence of
the compensation schemes like many
perhaps not all people here would argue
that the Windrush compensation scheme
for example was hindered by its lack of
arms length from the home office and
secondly could I also ask in
anticipation that the government does
accept recommendations about the scope
of the the compensation scheme could he
look to use information from the
infected blood support schemes to start
registering and verifying those who will
qualify right now in order to send save
some time further down the line minister
we are as part of the work I've alluded
to uh looking at a whole range of uh
compensation schemes
um and they come in different shapes and
sizes there's been none from the arm
windrushing refers to on forces
compensation scheme from the MOG
tribunal work um but there is a uh
the the solution of an ALB wholly
separate from uh government uh with uh
holy separate from government and paying
out the schemes it was uh Innovative
approach to an um to an unprecedented uh
issue and that's something which we are
working through that would have uh the
Independence that The Honorable
gentleman refers to that does bring with
it uh consequences as well in terms of
accountability for uh for expenditure so
we just need to we're working through
all of those issues he's he's wise to to
raise them on the on the point of view
of rate of registering uh potential
beneficiaries uh the current infected
blood uh schemes uh I believe were that
were the basis uh for the payment last
year of interim payments to uh those
infected and bereaved Partners I think
so Brian is very clear in saying uh that
for the scheme to widen we would need a
new registration scheme that goes
further than that and recognizes others
who've been affected but are not
included within the uh the invented
blood scheme but it's a good point they
want to protective races Jim Shannon
thank you Mom can I thank the minister
uh very much for a step and a special
command honorable lady for Kingston Hull
North I think it is uh for her dog
determination on this issue at every
case I think every one of us who has
constitons who suffer from this this uh
contaminated blood oh that honorable
lady uh many thanks so we thank her
publicly in this chamber today I'm very
pleased of the news that ahead of the
federal report the terminals issued the
recommendation that compensation has
given minister with compensation for
health issues the reality for money is
this uh that each week that passes is
worsening Health more care needed and
the compensation would greatly enhance
the quality of end of life for some of
these people who we know are coming to
that stage so I I the minister I said
very respectfully is a minister with
compassion and understands the issue so
will the minister consent to fast
tracking this recommendation while so
winning the rest of the report and
particularly for those end of life
Clements
Minister
um I Thank The Honorable gentleman
indeed all the members who contributed
to this um statement the he makes a very
powerful uh Point as so often and it's a
powerful point that comes out from to
Brian uh langstaff's uh report we will
do the work we will come back to uh this
place uh having uh done so uh there is a
powerful case being made by uh sir Brian
but the work needs to be undertaken we
do need to do that uh properly and I
look forward to coming back to the house
in uh due course uh when we've made more
progress
I thank the minister for his uh
statement and we now ah which of order
Sir Christopher choke Madam Deputy
speaker can I seek your help what can be
done to force ministers to honor
commitments made to this house at
dispatch box
on the 24th of March the vaccines
minister to whom I've given notice of
this point of order during my German
debate about covid-19 vaccine victims
promised to come to an early meeting of
the appg on vaccine damage
despite exhaustive efforts it has proved
impossible to obtain any date from the
minister we've offered any time any
place but we can't get any offer back
from her or her Department
today I attended the inquest into one
vaccine victim Dr Stephen Wright whose
Widow and mother heard the coroner
confirmed that Stephen's death at the
age of 32 was caused by the AstraZeneca
vaccine
we heard earlier from the paymaster
general that the government is very keen
to hear the voices of victims
as it is now more than six months that
I've been trying to get the health
ministers to meet vaccine victims the
paymaster General's words don't ring
very true this is just not good enough
and we owe it to people like the victims
of Dr Stephen Wright and his widow and
children we owe them something more than
the government is currently given we owe
them respect from the government which
they're not currently receiving